chaque semaine de nouveaux produits
alimentaires nous sont proposés sont ils
à prendre ou à laisser aujourd'hui des
produits qui feront plaisir aux plus
petits comme aux plus grands du fromage
avec probiotiques de petits fruits
enrobées de chocolat des croustilles
intrigante et du yogourt à saveur de
barbe à papa
honnêtement je suis tombé en bas de ma
chaise quand j'ai vu cette nouvelle
saveur là parce qu'on va se dire les
vraies choses c'est un peu en
contradiction avec l'image où laura
santé qu'on adore nieuwbourg avec un
bonbon comme la barbe à papa cela dit je
me suis réconcilié avec le produit à
partir du moment où j'ai commencé à
l'analyse et c'est bel et bien un logo
exactement la même composition
exactement la même valeur nutritive on a
donc ajouté aaron des saveurs pour les
couleurs j'imagine on nous dit c'est ce
qu'on voit dans la liste d'ingrédients
que tout est naturel de dents et son si
j'avoue que ça m'a fait un peu sourire
parce que qu'est-ce que de la saveur
naturelle ou des barbapapas je pense pas
qu'elle ait grand chose de naturel
d'abord parce qu'on sait pas si c'est de
la barbe à papa sauvages ou d'élevage
comme double nature et ne sais pas cela
dit comme c'est un produit qui s'adresse
aux enfants j'apprécie le fait que
yoplait se soit donné la peine de
développer ou de faire développer un
arôme de barbe à papa qu'ils soient
faits d'ingrédients de source naturelle
parce qu'on sait que les arômes
artificiels ou les colorants artificiels
peuvent avoir certains effets néfastes
pour la santé le
sillon
finale barbe à papa mais j'aime plus
proche de la feuille c'est drôle oui
c'est très subtil moi j'avoue que je
veux pas très bavarde à tabac mais au
moins où
ça confirme qu'on n'a pas affaire à
quelque chose qui est très sucré qui est
très bon alors à prendre le dessus mais
franchement pour moi ce serait pas de
saveur que j'encourage rien consommer à
l'année parce que ça reste qu'on est
dans l'univers du bonbon cela dit si on
le congèle ça peut faire d'excellents
c'est comme si cette glace et est
comparativement aux autres petits trous
qui se retrouvent sur le marché qui sont
vraiment justes de l'eau sucrée coloré
très chimiques sont moins on a affaire à
quelque chose qui me treated qui est
agréable à manger donc pour l'été très
bonne collation
[Musique]
pour les petits et pour les grands fils
et l'eau mais la différence ici c'est
qu'on a un ajout de probiotiques faut
savoir que c'est à la barre avec des
actes eux mans le même produit que le
fils et l'oma regret qu'on connaît
depuis des années la seule différence
c'est qu'on a ajouté 1 milliards de
bactéries probiotiques des premiers
succès des petits micro-organismes ami
qui travaille de concert avec les
micro-organismes qu'on a naturellement
dans notre corps dans l'intestin
essentiellement et qui ont vraiment un
rôle majeur sur le métier de notre santé
général un bémol
un milliard c'est un minimum pour qu'on
puisse commencer à parler bénéfice
quelconque sur la santé donc un bon
ajout mais il faut pas oublier quand
même le reste de notre alimentation donc
à prendre ou à laisser est ce que c'est
un must absolu ou à faire le détour
absolument faux absolument encore une
fois l'ensemble de l'alimentation est
plus importante que simplement son mais
c'est définitivement une belle option
pour ajouter du problème c'est qu'à
notre élément il de mal on est dans le
festival suremballage on pourrait
prendre un morceau de cheddar qui
contient déjà des biens des bactéries le
trancher en bâtonnets
c'est la faiblesse numéro un de ces
types de produits low avec ou sans
problématique parce que c'est l'ensemble
de la gamme qui est comme ça t'en
[Musique]
nouvelle gamme donc de petits fruits
enrobées de chocolat noir 57% miss crise
ce sont des fruits antilles c'est ce que
je trouve vraiment intéressant de ce
produit il ya celle ci ça fait beaucoup
et pense évidemment aux pères trappistes
qui nous offre des années les petits
bleus enrobées de chocolat absolument si
on va trouver ça dans la section de
surgelés épicerie et on doit décongeler
avant de servir le fait qu'il soit
surgelés c'est très frais embauche donc
c'est vraiment très agréable à consommer
j'apprécie le fait aussi que
l'entreprise ne pas ajouter de sucre
d'arômes colorants quelconque aux fruits
on a vraiment l'équivalent d'un fruits
surgelés entier naturel mais deux bémols
si je peux en dire 2 1 on ne prenait pas
la provenance des fraises et des
framboises jeu rennais savoir d'où elles
viennent d'autant plus qu'on sait que
les bleuets sont des bleuets du lac
saint jean aussi c'est un produit qui
est quand même relativement dispendieux
on parle de 7 dollars les sacs de 200
grammes donc à prendre ou à laisser moi
j'avais peu de mort effet sur moi ça
prend mais bon c'est définitivement une
belle idée de desserts à découvrir je
voudrais quand même dire qu'on n'arrive
en saison 2 des petits fruits au québec
donc pendant qu'on est en saison je
privilégierai d'acheter des petits
fruits locaux frais et de les tremper
nous mêmes dans des basses et de
chocolat fondu ce serait plus économique
est tout aussi savoureux
[Musique]
nous avons ici différents sacs de
croustilles qui s'appelle rambo potato
nouveaux produits lancés par un couple
de l'ontario l'année dernière c'est rare
que je m'exclame et de vendée devant des
croustilles mais non parce que si je
dois dire que je suis impressionné
est-ce que j'ai devant moi un
nutritionniste qui ma foi s'extasie
devant des sacs de croustilles et j'en
suis presque gêné
l'ensemble du produit et bien ancré sur
des valeurs de développement durable et
tout trier les pommes de tensions
locales elles sont biologiques elles
n'ont pas été épluchés on a gardé la
couleur de peau de gaspillage à ce
niveau leur l'huile qui est utilisée est
une excellente huile aucun ingrédient
superflu le sac est compostable je suis
impressionné mais pourquoi c'est
intéressant d'avoir un sac compostable
pour des croustilles juste au québec on
consomme des millions de sacs de chips à
chaque année or les emballages
traditionnel des tubes ce ne sont pas
recyclables tranquille a consommé des
crudités ça reste un aliment plaisir une
collation plaisir qui est très apprécié
des consommateurs il était temps qu'on
revienne avec cette proposition là mais
encore une fois au moins il le produit
qui est à l'intérieur aussi se tient
aussi avec réponse est oui la main
touches je te ramène dans le droit
chemin
ça reste des cheats commence bien c'est
aussi groc la majorité des critiques on
est sur le marché c'est ça l'est mais
raisonnablement et il ya très peu ou pas
de sucre ajouté alors que dans la
plupart des crous t il n'y en a parfois
vraiment
bon comme ça c'est léger on voit qu'il
ya ces zones mans on vote la pomme de
terre aussi les rambo pour rich épices à
prendre les c4 gâtés avec des
croustilles aussi bien y aller avec un
produit comme celui là qui est local qui
est bien fait et qui encore une fois
faire ça alors aussi pour
l'environnement c'est un peu plus cher
que les autres mais une gâterie plaisir
qui dans mon corps
mais c'est lui